Je vais vous donner 4 exemples précis - et puis je terminerai sur --
comment une société nommée Silk (Soie) a triplé ses ventes en faisant une chose.
Comment l'artiste Jeff Koons est passé du statut d'inconnu,
à celui de faire tout un tas d'argent et avoir beaucoup d'impact,
à la manière dont Frank Gehry a redéfini ce que signifie d'être un architecte.
Et un de mes plus grands échecs en tant que marketeur ces dernières années,
avec un label que j'ai crée et le CD appelé «Sauce».
Mais avant tout cela, je dois vous parler du pain en tranches, et d'un gars nommé Otto Rohwedder.
Avant que le pain en tranches soit inventé dans les années 1910,
je me demande ce qu'on disait?
La plus grande invention depuis... le télégraphe ou quelque chose comme ça.
Mais ce gars nommé Otto Rohwedder qui a inventé le pain en tranches,
s'est concentré, comme la plupart des inventeurs, uniquement sur la partie brevets et fabrication.
Et ce qui s'est passé avec l'invention du pain en tranches est que --
durant les 15 premières années après que le pain en tranches ait été disponible
personne n'en acheta, ne connaissait le produit. Ce fut un échec total.
Et la raison en est que, jusqu'à l'arrivée de Wonder qui comprit
la façon de répandre l'idée du pain en tranches, personne n'en voulait.
Car le succès du pain en tranches,
comme le succès de presque tout ce dont nous avons parlé à cette conférence,
n'est pas toujours dû au brevet, ou comment fonctionne l'usine,
mais plutôt comment vous obtenez que votre idée se propage, ou pas.
Et je pense que la manière de faire pour obtenir ce qu'on veut,
ou causer le changement que vous voulez voir se produire,
est de trouver un moyen pour que vos idées se propagent.
Et je me fiche de savoir si vous tenez un café, si vous êtes un intellectuel,
dans les affaires, ou si vous volez en montgolfière.
Je pense que cela s'applique à tout le monde, quoi que nous fassions.
Que nous vivons dans un siècle de la diffusion des idées.
Que ceux qui propagent des idées, quelles qu'elles soient, gagnent.
Et quand je parle de ce sujet, je choisis généralement des entreprises
parce qu'elles se prêtent mieux à une présentation visuelle
et parce que c'est le moyen le plus facile de suivre des résultats.
Mais je veux que vous me pardonniez quand j'utilise ces exemples
parce que je parle de n'importe quoi qui peut occuper votre temps
Au cœur de la diffusion des idées, il y a la télévision et les choses comme ça.
La télé et les médias de masse ont vraiment facilité une certaine diffusion des idées.
J'appelle ça le complexe télé-industriel.
La façon dont le complexe télé-industriel marche, est que vous achetez de la pub,
interrompez certaines personnes -- qui parleront de votre produit.
Puis vous utilisez ce bouche à oreille, pour vendre plus de produits.
Et avec ce profit, vous achetez plus de pubs.
Et le système continue indéfiniment,
de la même façon que les complexes militaires et industriels fonctionnaient, il y a longtemps.
Et ce système, nous l'avons entendu hier,
si nous pouvions arriver en première page de Google,
si nous pouvions trouver comment être promu là,
si nous pouvions trouver comment attraper les gens par le cou,
et leur dire ce que nous voulons faire.
Si nous faisons cela et que les gens y prêtent attention, nous avons gagné.
Ce complexe télé-industriel a bercé mon enfance et probablement la vôtre.
Je veux dire, tout ces produits ont réussi car quelqu'un a trouvé
comment toucher les gens d'une manière qu'ils n'attendaient pas,
d'une manière qu'il ne voulait pas nécessairement avec une pub,
encore et encore jusqu'à ce qu'ils se mettent à l'acheter.
Et la chose qui s'est passée, c'est qu'ils ont annulé le complexe télé-industriel.
Ça fait juste quelques années,
que tous les gens qui font du marketing ont découvert,
que cela ne fonctionnait plus comme avant.
Cette image est vraiment floue, je m'excuse, j'avais un rhume quand je l'ai prise.
Mais le produit dans la boîte bleue au milieu est mon fétiche.
Exactement. Je vais à l'épicerie, je suis malade, j'ai besoin d'acheter des médicaments.
Le brand manager de ce produit bleu a dépensé 100 millions de dollars
pour essayer de m'interpeller durant une année.
100 millions de dollars pour m'interpeller avec des pub à la télé, dans les magazines, des spams,
des coupons de réductions et autres promotions...
et je pouvais ignorer chacun de ses messages.
Et j'ai ignoré chacun de ses messages car je n'avais pas besoin d'un anti-douleur.
J'achète cette chose dans la boîte jaune car je l'ai toujours fait.
Et je ne vais pas investir une minute de mon temps à résoudre leur problème,
car ça ne m'intéresse pas.
Voici un magazine appelé Hydrate. 180 pages sur l'eau.
(Rires)
Oui. Des articles sur l'eau, des pubs sur l'eau.
Imaginez ce qu'était le monde, il y a 40 ans,
quand il y avait juste le "Saturday Evening Post", "Time" et "Newsweek".
Maintenant il y a des magazines sur l'eau.
Un nouveau produit de Coca-Cola Japon -- la salade d'eaux.
(Rires)
OK. Coca-Cola Japon sort un nouveau produit toutes les 3 semaines.
Car ils n'ont aucune idée de ce qui va fonctionner ou pas.
Je n'aurais pas pu écrire cela mieux moi-même. C'est sorti il y a 4 jours --
J'ai entouré les points importants pour que vous puissiez les voir.
Ils ont sorti ça... Arby va dépenser 85 millions de dollars pour promouvoir un gant au four
avec la voix de Tom Arnold,
en espérant que cela va amener les gens à aller à Arby's et acheter un sandwich roast-beef.
(Rires)
Là, j'ai essayé de m'imaginer ce que pourrait être un film d'animation publicitaire
avec Tom Arnold, qui vous pousserait à prendre votre voiture,
conduire à travers la ville et acheter un sandwich roast beef.
(Rires)
Là, c'est Copernic, et il avait raison,
quand il parlait à quelqu'un qui a besoin d'écouter votre idée.
Le monde tourne autour de moi. Moi, moi, moi, moi. Ma personne préférée -- moi.
Je ne veux recevoir d'email de personne, je veux recevoir un "e-moi".
(Rires)
Donc les consommateurs, et pas seulement ceux qui achètent des choses à Safeway,
Je parle des gens du Ministère de la Défense qui pourraient acheter quelque chose,
ou ces gens, vous savez, au New Yorker qui pourraient imprimer votre article.
Les consommateurs ne se préoccupent pas du tout de vous, ils s'en fichent.
Une raison à cela est -- qu'ils ont beaucoup plus de choix qu'auparavant,
et beaucoup moins de temps.
Et dans un monde où nous avons trop de choix
et trop peu de temps, la chose la plus évidente à faire est d'ignorer les choses.
Et ma parabole ici est que si vous conduisez sur la route
et que vous voyez une vache, vous allez continuer à conduire
car vous avez déjà vu des vaches avant.
Les vaches, c'est invisible. Les vaches, c'est ennuyeux.
Quelle personne va s'arrêter et dire -- Oh, regarde, une vache. Personne.
(Rires)
Mais si la vache était violette -- ce n'est pas super comme effet spécial?
Je peux le refaire si vous le voulez.
Si la vache était violette, vous la remarqueriez pour un moment.
Je veux dire, que si toutes les vaches étaient violettes vous seriez indifférent à celle-là aussi.
La chose qui va décider ce qui mérite d'être un sujet de discussion,
d'être fait, d'être changé,
d'être acheté, d'être construit est
est-ce remarquable?
Et remarquable est un mot vraiment cool parce qu'on pense que cela signifie simplement soigné,
mais cela veut dire aussi -- qui mérite qu'on fasse une remarque.
Et c'est l'essence même de la propagation d'une idée.
Voici deux des voitures les plus appréciées au USA: Une voiture géante de 55 000$
assez grosse pour contenir une mini dans son coffre.
Les gens payent le plein tarif pour ces deux voitures, et la seul chose qu'elles ont en commun
c'est qu'elles n'ont rien en commun.
(Rires)
Chaque semaine le DVD n°1 en Amérique, en terme de ventes, change.
Ce n'est jamais "Le Parrain", ce n'est jamais "Citizen Kane",
c'est toujours un film de série B, avec une star de second rang.
Mais la raison pour laquelle, le film est n°1 est car c'est la semaine de sa sortie.
Car c'est nouveau, car c'est frais.
Car les gens voient ça et se disent -- Je ne savais pas que cela existait --
et ils le remarquent.
Deux des gros succès de ces 20 dernières années dans le commerce --
un magasin qui vend des produits super chers dans une boîte bleu,
et un autre qui vend des produits tellement bon marché qu'ils sont presque vendus coûtant.
La seule chose qu'ils ont en commun est qu'ils sont différents.
Nous sommes maintenant dans le business de la mode quel que soit notre métier,
nous sommes dans le business de la mode.
Et la chose est que les gens dans le business de la mode
savent ce que c'est que d'être dans ce business, car ils sont habitués.
Le reste d'entre nous doit trouver comment penser comme eux.
Comment comprendre que ce n'est pas seulement interrompre les gens avec des pubs géantes
ou insister pour rencontrer les gens.
Mais c'est un processus totalement différent qui détermine quelles idées se propagent,
et celles qui ne se propagent pas.
Cette chaise -- Ils ont vendu pour 1 milliard de dollars de chaises Aeron
en réinventant ce qui signifie vendre une chaise.
Ils ont transformé une chaise d'un objet quelconque acheté par le service achat,
en un objet avec un statut symbolique où vous vous asseyez au travail.
Cet homme, Lionel Poilâne, le plus célèbre boulanger du monde --
il est mort il y a deux ans et demi,
et il était un de mes héros et très cher ami.
Il vivait à Paris. L'année dernière, il a vendu pour 10 millions de dollars de pains français.
Chaque miche est préparée dans une de ses boulangeries, par un boulanger à la fois, dans un four à bois.
Et quand Lionel a commencé sa boulangerie les français, le huaient pour ça.
Ils ne voulaient pas acheter son pain. Cela ne ressemblait pas à une baguette.
Ce n'était pas ce qu'ils attendaient.
C'était soigné, c'était remarquable, et doucement le bouche à oreille a fonctionné
jusqu'à ce que cela devienne finalement le pain officiel des restaurants 3 étoiles de Paris.
Maintenant il est présent à Londres, et livre le monde entier par FedEx.
Ce que les marketeurs faisaient c'était des produits moyens pour les gens moyens.
C'était ça le marketing de masse.
Arrondir les bords, viser le centre,
c'est le gros du marché.
Ils ignoraient les geeks,
et Dieu me pardonne, les retardataires.
C'était juste viser le centre.
Mais dans un monde où le complexe télé-industriel est en panne,
je ne pense pas que ce soit une stratégie que nous voulons encore utiliser.
Je pense que la stratégie que nous voulons utiliser n'est pas de marketer ces gens
car ils sont vraiment bons pour nous ignorer.
Mais marketer ces gens car ça les intéresse.
Ce sont ces gens qui sont obsédés par les choses.
Et quand vous leur parlez ils écoutent
car ils aiment écouter -- Ca les concerne.
Et si vous êtes chanceux, ils en parleront à leurs amis
du reste de la courbe, et cela se propagera.
Cela se propagera sur la courbe entière.
Ils ont une chose appelé otaku -- c'est un formidable mot japonais.
Cela décrit le désir de quelqu'un tellement obsédé qu'il, par exemple,
traverse tout Tokyo pour essayer les derniers ramen à la mode,
car c'est ce qu'ils font. Ils deviennent obsédés par ça.
Pour faire un produit, pour marketer une idée,
pour trouver une solution à un problème
qui ne tienne pas compte d'un otaku,
c'est impossible.
A la place, vous devez trouver un groupe qui s'intéresse réellement
et désespérement à ce que vous avez à dire.
Parlez leur et facilitez leur la tâche d'en parler à leurs amis.
Il y a une sauce piquante otaku, mais il n'y pas de moutarde otaku.
C'est pour cela qu'il y a des tas et des tas de sortes de sauces piquantes,
et peu de sortes de moutarde.
Pas parce qu'il est difficile de faire une moutarde intéressante
-- vous pouvez faire une moutarde intéressante --
Mais les gens ne le font pas car personne n'est obsédé par ça,
et donc personne n'en parle à ses amis.
Krispy Kreme a compris tout cela.
Krispy Krema a une stratégie, et ce qu'ils font c'est,
qu'ils entrent dans une ville, et ils parlent aux gens otaku (avec une obsession),
puis ils propagent cela dans la ville
aux gens qu'ils croisent dans la rue.
Ce yoyo que vous voyez coûte 112 dollars, mais il dort pendant 12 minutes.
Tout le monde n'en veut pas mais ils s'en fichent.
Ils veulent parler aux gens que ça intéresse, et peut-être que cela se propagera.
Ces gens fabriquent les enceintes de voitures les plus puissantes au monde.
(Rires)
C'est aussi bruyant qu'un jet 747, vous ne pouvez pas entrer
la voiture possède des glaces pare-balles
car sinon cela soufflerait le pare-brise.
Mais le fait est que si quelqu'un
veut mettre des enceintes dans sa voiture,
et qu'ils ont l'otaku
ou qu'ils ont entendu d'une personne qui l'a,
ils y vont et choississent ce modèle.
C'est vraiment simple -- vous vendez aux personnes qui écoutent.
et peut-être, juste peut-être que ces gens en parleront à leurs amis.
Donc quand Steve Jobs parle à 50 000 personnes durant sa présentation,
tous connectés de 130 pays différents
et en train de regarder cette pub de 2 heures --
c'est la seule chose qui conserve sa compagnie dans le business --
ces 50 000 personnes sont tellement fanatiques
pour regarder une pub de 2 heures, et en parler avec leurs amis.
Pearl Jam, 96 albums sortis ces deux dernières années.
Chacun est bénéficiaire. Comment?
Ils les vendent seulement sur leur site web.
Ces gens qui l'achètent sur le site ont l'otaku,
puis ils en parlent à leurs amis, et cela se propage et se propage.
Ce lit d'hopital coûte 10 000 dollars, 10 fois le prix standard.
Mais les hopitaux l'achètent plus vite qu'aucun autre modèle.
Le vernis à ongles Hard Candy (Bonbon dur), ne plait pas à tout le monde,
mais pour ceux qui l'adorent, ils en parlent comme des fous.
Cette peinture que vous voyez là a sauvé l'entreprise de peinture Dutch Boy,
et les a rendu riches. Elle coûte 35 pour cent de plus qu'une peinture normale
car Dutch Boy a fait un pot dont les gens parlent car c'est remarquable.
Ils n'ont pas juste sorti une nouvelle pub sur le produit,
ils ont changé ce que signifiait concevoir un produit de peinture.
AmIhotornot.com (SuisJeSexyOuPas.com) -- chaque jour 250 000 personnes vont sur le site,
dirigé par 2 volontaires, et je peux vous dire qu'ils sont durs en notation, et
(Rires)
ils ne sont pas arrivés là en faisant beaucoup de pub.
Ils sont arrivés là en étant remarquables,
parfois un peu TROP remarquables.
Ce cadre photo a une fil derrière qui
permet de le brancher sur une prise au mur.
Mon père a cela sur son bureau,
et il voit ses petits-enfants changer chaque jour.
Et chaque personne qui entre dans son bureau
entend toute l'histoire de comment cela a fini sur son bureau.
Une personne à la fois, l'idée se propage.
Ce ne sont pas des diamants, pas vraiment.
C'est fait à partir de crémations.
Après qu'on vous a incinéré, vous pouvez devenir une pierre précieuse.
(Rires)
Oh, vous aimez ma bague? C'est ma grand mère.
Le business qui grandit le plus vite dans l'industrie mortuaire.
Mais vous n'avez pas besoin d'être Ozzie Osborne --
vous n'avez pas besoin d'être quelqu'un de super outrageux pour faire ça.
Ce que vous devez faire et trouver ce que les gens veulent vraiment et leur donner.
Quelques règles rapide pour conclure.
La première: le design est libre à partir d'une certaine échelle.
Et les gens qui arrivent avec des choses remarquables
le plus souvent réussissent à concevoir une design qui fonctionne pour eux.
Deuxièmement: la chose la plus risquée à faire est d'être trop prudent.
Procter and Gamble sait cela, n'est-ce pas?
Le modèle entier de Procter and Gamble
est des produits moyens pour les gens moyens.
C'est risqué. La chose prudente à faire aujourd'hui est d'être à la marge,
d'être remarquable.
Et être très bon est une des pire choses que vous pouvez faire.
Très bon, c'est ennuyeux. Très bon, c'est la moyenne
Peu importe si vous faites un album de musique,
ou si vous êtes un architecte, ou si vous devez faire un traité de sociologie.
Si c'est très bon, cela ne va pas marcher, car personne ne le remarquera.
Donc mes trois histoires.
Silk (Soie). Mettez un produit qui n'a pas besoin d'être en section refrigérée
à cote du milk (lait) de la section réfrigérée.
Les ventes ont triplé. Pourquoi?
Lait, lait, lait, lait, lait -- pas lait.
Pour les personnes cherchant du lait,
c'était remarquable.
Ils n'ont pas triplé leurs ventes avec la publicité,
ils les ont triplées en faisant quelque chose de remarquable.
C'est une remarquable pièce artistique. Vous n'avez pas à l'aimer,
mais un chien de 12m de haut en buisson
au milieu de New York, c'est remarquable.
Frank Gehry n'a pas juste changé un musée,
il a changé l'économie entière d'une ville
en concevant une batiment que les gens viennent voir du monde entier.
Maintenant, dans d'innombrables réunions, vous savez,
le conseil municipal de Portland, ou d'une autre ville,
ils disent, nous avons besoin d'un architecte -- peut-on avoir Frank Gehry?
Car il a fait quelque chose qui était à la marge.
Et mon grand échec? J'ai créé un tout un
(Musique)
album de musique et j'espérais tout un tas d'autres albums de musique
au format SACD -- ce nouveau format remarquable --
et je l'ai marketé directement envers les gens possédant des stéréos à 20 000 dollars.
Les gens avec des stéréos à 20 000 dollars n'aiment pas la nouvelle musique.
(Rires)
Ce que vous devez donc faire est trouver les gens pour qui cela compte.
Les gens qui vont lever la main et dire,
"Je veux entendre quel va être votre nouveau produit,"
et leur vendre quelque chose.
Le dernier exemple que je veux vous donner.
C'est la carte de Soap Lake (Le lac savon) à Washington.
Comme vous pouvez voir, si ça c'est nulle part, c'est au milieu.
(Rires)
Mais ils ont un lac.
Et les gens avaient l'habitude de faire des kilomètres pour nager dans ce lac.
Ils ne le font plus. Les fondateurs ont donc dit, " Nous avons de l'argent à dépenser.
Que pouvons-nous construire ici?" Et comme la plupart des comités
ils allaient construire quelque chose de prudent.
Et puis, un artiste vint à eux - avec une véritable vision d'artiste --
il veut construire une lava lampe de 15m de haut au centre de la ville.
C'est une vache violette, c'est une chose que les gens remarquent.
Je ne sais pas pour vous mais s'ils le construisent, c'est là que je vais aller.
Merci beaucoup de votre attention.